au mois de novembre l'année dernière
quand il avait rencontré le pape
françois nous avions accompagné gilbert
aubry au vatican
trente ans plus tôt c'est ici que
c'était décidé le voyage de jean paul ii
à la réunion gilbert aubry s'en souvient
très bien
il avait d'abord fallu expliquer au pape
où se trouvait notre île on discute avec
lui ep alors il y avait un globe
terrestre l'a1 senti que son bureau
on va vers un globe terrestre ou fait
tourner blog bébé du sénat et il nous
dit maria bon et on lui dit mais comment
il ya quelque chose
venez voir et c'est comme ça que ça
s'est enclenchée il est 17 heures 13 ce
lundi prix c'est ainsi que le 1er mai
1989 jean paul 2 débarque à la réunion
en provenance de madagascar
gilbert aubry jeune évêque encore de 47
ans est monté à bord pour l'accueillir
le pape descend de la passerelle et
comme le veut la tradition ils baisent
le sol de la réunion avant d'être
accueilli par le premier ministre michel
rocard
les hymnes résonnent alors qu'ils
menaient du vatican puis marseillaise
et même en guise de réunionnais un
joyeux ça sent la banane l'auteur de la
chanson jacqueline farreyrol elle même
n'en est toujours pas revenu des banques
à la région et qu'est ce que je vois et
plein de petits enfants habillés tous de
blanc je crois joli comme tout et qui
chante et ça sent la banane et jean paul
2 comme ça devant très recueillie devant
ça sent la banane là franchement j'ai
hurlé de rire qui met de la joie de vous
revoir sur votre propre sort
je remercie mon cher aubry de m'avoir
invité à la réunion gilbert aubry lui se
rappelle qu'il y avait tellement de
monde sur la route entre l'aéroport et
saint-denis qu'on avait frôlé l'accident
lorsqu'une partie de la foule avait
débordé sur la chaussée au niveau du
butor puis à la préfecture
le pape avait rencontré les responsables
religieux et politiques de l'île
notamment le jeune gilbert annette tout
juste élu pour la première fois maire de
saint denis
le pape avait ensuite repris la
papamobile pour rejoindre la cathédrale
de saint-denis où l'attendait tous les
prêtres religieux et religieuses du
département
ce soir là après un dîner à l'évêché le
pape avait dormi dans la chambre de
l'évêque qui était pour sa part allé
dormir dans le grenier de l'évêché
le lendemain matin jean paul ii a
rendez-vous dans les jardins de l'évêché
avec les jeunes catholiques de la
réunion pour les jeunes de la réunion
aurait aimé être à notre place
c'est en leur nom que nous sommes ici
pour une rencontre unique au monde et ça
fait je vous remets ce foulard venant de
tous les jeunes de la réunion
oui on peut vous masser autour du cou
très simple
[Musique]
mais l'image qui restera de cette visite
c'est le plus grand rassemblement jamais
vu à la réunion cent mille personnes
peut-être 120000 rassemblés sur
l'esplanade de la trinité à saint denis
rapporté à la population d'alors cela
signifie qu'un réunionnais sur cinq a
assisté ce jour là la messe célébrée par
le pape
pour la communion on avait imaginé un
système de distribution avec des
centaines de paniers en vacoa placés
dans des corbeilles en osier
il y avait tant de monde qu il avait
même fallu prévoir une camionnette pour
les amener aux personnes installées le
plus loin
gilbert aubry lui se souvient de
l'émotion de jean paul ii et il était
heureux de cette visite là et quand ils
distribuent elle en communion jeter à
côté de lui je voyais qu'il avait les
larmes qui coulaient parce qu'ils
voyaient tous les visages qui se
succéder comme ça et c'était le monde
entier qui défilaient devant lui avec
tous les types humains et ce métissage
que nous avons à la réunion il était là
dans une plénitude extraordinaire
de ces deux jours passés à la réunion il
reste également sept petites phrases
entré dans l'histoire reste pas dans le
fénoir
je remercie de tout coeur votre sainteté
c'est gilbert aubry qui l'avait écrit ce
qu'il raconte qu'il en a eu
l'inspiration une nuit pendant le
cyclone fienga alors qu'il préparait
dans sa chambre la visite du pape
il avait ensuite fallu donner à jean
paul ii une petite leçon de créole
pendant qu'on sortait la sacristie vos
vania sur le podium avec cette foule de
5000 personnes qui étaient là ni très
simple vous allez dans un instant
prononcé l'homélie dans votre texte
voilà il ya cette phrase là voilà
comment il faudra prononcer et je lui ai
fait une leçon de prononciation du
créole pendant ce trajet entre la
sacristie est le podium elle me dit re
re re compris est ce moi vous dire en
gros le et essayez de vous dire encore
rayspan en peignoir bien dans la lumière
soleil il est soleil y dort la lune
il est là lui y dort jo tu m'aimes la
lumière y est un pas et le lendemain
quand je leur amène jeter dans la
papamobile avec lui d'où est allé les
gens partout partout partout alors on
leur amenons dans la ligne droite près
du pont de la rivière des pluies
il y avait des montagnes qui était
dégagé
piton des neiges on le voyait bien les
montagnes était bleu alors il dit oh
c'est beau ici c'est le paradis
terrestre jeudi très saint père c'est le
paradis terrestre mais est allé pêcher
alors n'hésitez puis me dit mais le
péché est là commence au paradis
terrestre
c'était il ya trente ans la première
visite d'un pape à la réunion la seule
sans doute encore pour longtemps puisque
le pape françois lui il ira à madagascar
et maurice sans passer par notre île
[Musique]